هذه
أسقط المؤيدون الدعاية 31 المستفادة
عمر الدخل
هذا كل شيء مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
اشترك
ماذا حدث
هو - هي
مرة أخرى منزوعة السلاح من اليونان
تسليح الجزر على جسر تان
لا تستسلم
يتوافق مع الاتفاقيات الدولية
ندعوكم للعمل
لن أتخلى عن حقوقي في بحر إيجه
تسليح الجزر
الاتفاقيات الدولية في
الصلاحيات الممنوحة له
الامتناع عن استخدامه عند الضرورة
لن تتوقف
[موسيقى]
هل هو شيء ضائع لا ينتمي إليه مثل العاهرة
قلنا أ
[موسيقى]
هذه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
التفكير في Yecibu من بحر إيجه لديه الغجر
اعتني بجسم مساحة الأدوات الخاصة بك بشكل جيد
مفتاح البريد خاطئ في فيلم أفلاطون ليلا
اتصلت لأنها كانت كاديلاك
ليس مصطفى أويسال
هو
[موسيقى]
ماذا تشتري كهدية
تاريخ مختلف بما فيه الكفاية أو تجميع فانوس
تحدث إلى سيفاس ، بطل السلام
تافاس سايت فولو والدماغ تركيا
بوليفيا
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنه كان ليسلي ، حالته في الهجرة
تعال كعمل
هل حصلت على فستان بطريقة ما
أقسم ، برافو ، اعتني بنفسك ، Alifaki قانوني
بحرف المدينة المقدسة
kinetika d-loop لقضاء وقت ممتع ، صوتك واحد
ها
[موسيقى]
تحدثنا معه
في حديثنا معه
حتى لا نجلب بيننا دول ثالثة
على الرغم من الحصول على الدجاج
ها هي رحلة الأسبوع الماضي إلى أمريكا
وفي مجلس الشيوخ
مهما كلف الأمر ضد تركيا
كما يتكلم
لا تعطي f-16s لتركيا.
بالقول
يبدو الأمر كما لو أنه يلقن أمريكا بهذه الطريقة.
لكن
[موسيقى]
لدينا اجتماع المجلس الاستراتيجي هذا العام
فعلت من أجلي الآن
ليس الكثير من الخراجات